a terra tutti ragazzi e detenute questo
nuovo video sono la vj e oggi siano
soggette quattro ragazzi mi fanno male
voglia lega bisti giorni perché lo
sforzato un casino ma comunque
nonostante questo ragazzino non potevano
fare video perché già ieri non avevo
fatto e quindi chi se ne fotte vogliamo
lo stesso se l'avete richiesto in
tantissimi quindi ragazzi non poteva non
farlo rock ero ragazzina precisazione
prima di cominciare abbiate paura di ciò
che state per vedere ok bene che questa
canzone la conosco a memoria ma non so
cos'è
e la tanto del robot più sexy di sempre
[Musica]
e allora capisce questa canzone
praticamente la sua memoria
perché scrive chi mi piace però non vai
bellico verso i balli cioè come come
tutte le altre del resto
[Musica]
parolacce
che cosa è di che cazzo
[Musica]
io non ho mai ballato così forse questo
è l'episodio più ridicolo e assurdo
[Musica]
torniamo
oltre a [ __ ] ragazzi un secondo i
prego ragazzi ma chi no non l'ho fermo
fermo
[Musica]
fatelo smettere ma che si spazzola
ragazzi basta salire troppo cantante
matteo
lungo e bass commosso bibli ass
[Musica]
i ragazzi sono morto basta non c'è più
pagherò buono e quattrini a chiunque lo
faccio a smettere basta usciamo più
neanche noi e amati scorso allora la fa
[Musica]
sì ma ce l'ha con me cioè sto stronzo
ragazzi sto stronzo mi sta guardando e
dicendo adesso studi e non tidone anche
lo yen ha perso tempo ho detto ragazzi
c'era una delle mie canzoni preferite
anche maledizione ragazzi sono distrutto
va bene io sono troppo stanco ma non può
più sul tranquillo mi butto successo
perché non mi butto successo nel senso
che faccio una canzone di cash non è che
mi butto ma poche sciarelli dando al
piano perché se non fai niente la
coscienza henry mortacci tua
sono sono già distrutto non marco
iniziato vabbè dettagli non fa niente se
lo facciamo lo stesso te
l'aria troppo seria così spero di non
aver messo testo vocale a questo punto
perché era veramente tutta la cosa
[Musica]
si no
non ci posso credere ragazzi tornando
tutto nuovo è perché sono trapanese
[Musica]
guardate insieme a fabio voglio vedere
chi è chi vuoi farla insieme a me
ragazzi non penso ci sarà nessuno su 192
mila persone ma io ci provo comunque
[Musica]
mi piace dopo di che cosa s
google
da ragazzo quando tre stelle non posso
finire senza le stelle non è accettabile
quando questa è la verità
dan brown da ragazzo la parola non
mettete su di me si aprono le scommesse
quote le due stelle prima che finisca
dai dai dai dai
[Musica]
non ci credo che curò assurdo con
l'ultima mossa l'ho presa c'è è stato
assurdo
mamma mia ragazzi faccio l'ultima fra
chiese non si fosse ancora capito sono
giusto un po stanco fuggiamo medda
capito ma facciamo questo perché mi
sembra mi sembra adatta alle mie
esigenze
speriamo di non fare figure di merda ma
la palla ero io so come allora spettate
che ok la posa la fase di te replica
giù le mani dal coni j poi ci pensa
valigie non c'è partita quando favino
bar di poche parole
mai così noi ma ragazzi mette fuori le
palle per fare come edificio domando già
mi spiace ma per abortiti ma mi piace
già qualcuno ti vuoi dire e spiegare
perché c'è il coniglio di rai verna che
quanti gelli pietro sono lo so perché
fai a scrivere lo stile favier nuovo
tipo di ruolo ragazzi mi piace troppo
e allora via alla giornata inventarlo
tutte fa vedere
[Musica]
no
ci posso credere non si possono tuta
mente crescere ragazzi preparati le
shopper partita di potenza
[Musica]
no
per farmi lo mette fuori
non vedo il cazzo
cairo
dietro famiglia squadra
vabbè avete voi mai visto una tigre che
balla in modo così sexy
lei ha visto troppo caldo per la merda
basta un pelo un peso di tigre boca è un
po in ritardo forse si regga sono morto
basta non ce la faccio veramente più
penso che la tigra sia ancora più stanca
di mezzo anche ragazzi concluso qui da
episodio perché veramente sono anche a
livello 12 sono veramente sfinito
segui dove è piaciuto come al solito
lasciato commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come ogni video
trovate nella descrizione senza vestiti
iscrivetevi e noi ci mettiamo nel
prossimo video per ragazzi